[Music] it's time to thre equalize people
KO jandro and I we intentionally turned
down screenings even though we got a lot for
this one cuz we were like no we owe it to the
audience who watched equalizer 1 and two
with us to watch equalizer 3 with us how
you doing Coy I'm so excited to find out the
genre I'm excited too yeah that's right there
was a tonal shift from one to two but I love
both of them people have really really enjoyed
it did well at the box office so ladies and
gentlemen you know what to do equalize that
like button whatever that means also uh I wanted
to say a really really really big thank you to
everyone who's been watching our videos first
and foremost as I segue to everyone who's been
purchasing some real reex apparel one of the
absolute best ways to support the channel we
got shirts like this one right here I call the
shop protection services shirt of course Pedro
Pascal from last of us and baby Yoda we just
launched this Ahsoka stip STI Shir lightsaber
scissors got space babies we got who influences
The influencers Watchmen inspired got a soda we
got a whole bunch more bottom line it is easily
one of the best ways to support the channel and
plus we put our own creativity into it ourselves
we were handson with it so thank you guys so much
and lastly full enaction watch along re single
with your own copy of The Equalizer 3 available
for super sex rejects over at our patreon page
we cover several things exclusively there with
reaction how and watch Longs included Coy chre
you ready so ready I am so ready to Let's get to
it that's so pretty wow I wonder what
this experience is like for people who
saw equalizer 2 when it first came out
then to wait for this whereas we saw them
this year two months ago yeah cuz I'm like
let's pick it up exactly pretty nice right
in yeah some people waited seven years
between the first and the third one yeah
exactly uh it's a it's a crime guys's got a
pitchfork in him I wouldn't
go that way you got a kid
great reveal shot yeah oh I love the
background use of hyper violence that
kid is Young Denzel he would grow up to be Denzel
Washington ooh
cool shutter speed shift damn damn
so the third one's a horror movie
oh wow they they really went right up close and
personal with that one I wanted us to experience
it these are awesome shots there's a lot
like violence in the background I love
it oh this is a violent opening they're
so good at making the villains awful in
different ways or is this Denzel's doing I'll
take either one either way violence I feel
like it's too violent for the protagonist
no no I think it's Denzel he's just lost
it oh I love elegant possible villains
yeah I'm really curious how this
goes still one shot I think so I think
it's still one shot since the threshold
got crossed right like since they followed
behind them that was really really pretty
damn the shadows and Lighting are
on point Who's their gaffer great
job every step yeah you're right
it is Denzel man that's cool to
throw it in the other person's
perspective yeah that Lighting on
him godamn right you to say I know what you
are what you are emphasis you took something
that didn't belong to you I'm here to take
it back even the guy with a gun hella look so
nervous love other particulate yeah your man
to my left finger on the trigger but he's a
foot Too Close which renders your man to my
right de already he just doesn't know it yet
I feel sorry for his family man has it missed
a step 9 seconds there it is that's what you
have to decide your fate damn it sounds like
jigsaw now boom boom [Music] oh oh oh oh he
shot him through his head he shot him through
his head oh my God the seven-year waight was
worth it I'm so glad we were patient for
seven years I love these movies so much
look at that shot I know it's gorgeous
holy crap again the Shadows are on point
beautiful ouch oh right up the exit ouch
it's so fascinating capturing it in this
perspective CU it paints him in almost
a villainous light cuz he's so brutal
but he is like we've seen it yeah but
we've rationalized it oh that music is
great spiderverse inspired this
one is a violent good time people
woo oh you I think the music works as
a great transition too whatever we're
going next look at the wine spilling with
the blood yeah it's excellent Sony loves
their it's got that like religious
symbolism that just plays all along
this so hyped three equalize bre in M now
okay God he's so cool he really is no
whoa whoa whoa oh no oh my God it threw
him off his game did you see that yeah he
just like that was yeah just that was not
like him that's really interesting I think he
like his Instinct was the kid was okay and it
wasn't oh dang he actually got clipped I
think he was checking is that what this
movie is about him having to retire because
he's not like on [Music] it this what has
existentialism dread dread looms if you went
to the theaters of coin I would be the exact
same thing it'd be everyone around us you guys
shut up existentialism see it the lighting is
on
oh damn holy [__] is he actually
going through this he's always
Invincible damn this is this is really punching
he fell onto a bullet oh maybe he started firing
like crazy because he got shot
in the back oh maybe just Panic
yeah that is the
theme always given us a different side of him
every movie giving the movie purpose justifying
it look he's so emotional this
time his emotions are on the
fences yep they certainly are oh man that's
that's one fen's reference per equalizer from
out of nowhere I'll pull it off I still haven't
seen fences I just know his hat it's just as fun
of a reaction oh yeah definitely and nice
drun that's a play watch us watch a play
thank you Andel what's your name that is not
a lie yeah I was wondering no h Philadelphia
where you supposed to be oh he said what
he said earlier talking about where you're
supposed to be dude are you the bad guy that
is the question and him not knowing old man
Robert needs another Cane to equalize
how long I uh three days today you
resurrected like Christ four more
days what a kind man I hope he's handicapped
for this whole movie I think that would be a
really fascinating part every like movie's
been so different he might be I mean one of
the things that people have often said is that
you know he is a little too Invincible yeah they
did a whole movie where he's mortal and how
he'd see the world not capable of acting on
it is this about him versing the Mafia
the whole Mafia well it seems like he's
versing like the Italian mafia right
cuz they would be ruling this cuz he's
paranoid every step he's taking yeah
what's he looking out for well that's
interesting I worry about him taking down the
mafia I don't know if he's in any shape too I
think you can pull it off he's Unstoppable oh my
God I'm Gonna Keep two for two I'm I got I can
do this all day he's got to come back though
slowly he needs a training day or [Laughter]
two interesting he where's
his wedding ring on his right
yeah
poison what if this one was just a slice
of Life of him healing Still Still invested
still be invested just watch him on screen
I'm Georg Boni I'm Jo this is my daughter
Gabby oh no I'm worried for Gio Dr is a very
good doctor he brought me to this world my
parents too almost everybody here what all
them man is very old and prolific I po your
cob behind the station for when you feel
better I didn't look in your backs why are
they willing to protect him so much immediately
it's cuz he's American everyone loves Americans
oh they didn't know he was unconscious
it's a friendly Canadian people love
Canadians so much more despair in his
performance yeah I'm really worried for
that kid and all these kind people cins
that's her Vineyard in Sicily 6.2 miles
south of who is this concerned citizen
you were talking to a Man on Fire just
now canina Arana Vineyards just south
of palmo crates imported from Middle
East Syria by the looks of it fruits tree
nuts spices I'm sorry but there's nothing
unusual about that wine I still view her
as a child actor every time I see her how
is she working at the CIA I never view
her as an adult repackaging operation
by the looks of it you're going to need a
physical access team you know all this how
just passing through thought it might be of
interest to you people what do you mean you
people so he's going to be like protecting
the people here I assume but he just put
his watch down which is how he equalizes so
is that like him like I'm I'm off I think he
wants to retire but you can't retire The Man on
Fire you already used that one I just rhyming
it this time all right that's fair somehow I
will working to take you to pelhem [Laughter]
123 wow this is the shadow movie I love the
lightting so much you just really get the
impression death is waiting for him it's
a really ominous everything editing tone
[Music] lighting feels like he's descending
the stairs to heaven what a cool like how did
they that shot s on a lift one day someone
does something unspeakable to someone else
and you do something about it cuz you can
it's who you are you've always been God it's
flashback this is cool whoa waa hardcore [Music]
Henry interesting oh the reflection man each
one of them gets darker about his view of
himself and everything yeah like the first an
action movie with knowledge of morality the
second when it's like the ramifications
this is like the despair like the the
weight yeah you really get the to really
throw it into his firsters point of view
completely undoes any glorification of
that moment oh yeah nothing's cool about
murdering a lot of people but the finale
still better be it's going to be awesome
with the watch the watch is going to go
back on you better still bring it F me
[Music]
it this guy is the master at making
friends with people at local shops
very attractive people just love denel I
know on the way
out I feel like there's going to be no violence
for like another another hour I'm cool man ATT
video it's an interesting structure to to
be like let's throw you into this and now
let's peel it back and deconstruct
him long game the unnerving the bad
elements no violence from him
there will be violence there
will be violence immediate violence looks to be
happening
pay your [Music]
taxes I don't know there's a lot of death
symbolism man dead fish come on symbolized
[Music] life I like this track this track is
cool something's building yeah son loves the
flare I think fuka really up this game on
the camera work here mhm the lock offs of
POV the like lifts yeah the long shots
too look how tangible this all is out of
the three movies this year set in Italy this
is the prettiest oh yeah really getting the
sense of the extra and stuff the environment
I feel like I'm here versus me watching here
mhm I suspect action scene it's
looming love how so much of
this is actually an Italian
yeah oh my
god
wow here consequences of not being obedient to
these guys the villainy is always so horrific
in these the violence feels violent leave
him there for everyone to see yeah we like
we're so desensitized to violence cuz it's
in every movie but like this is something
else that was so brilliant cuz I I kept
wondering why the camera was locked off
to keep him in Focus the guy in the wheelchair
the weakest and like least intimidating person
it's just a motion of just watching this
vulnerable elderly man violently murdered
there's nothing about the character you
know yeah for for grilled for roast yes
well
hello that's sucker what a great
jab no that I understand I'm
paying thank oh man I want Enzo as a
friend guy got doesn't have the money
and he's still helping out I love
free stuff oh what are they moving
O's that is that Roy yeah he left the office
he got promote approximately 11 million us
cameras they all went down at the same time
precisely 1816 is she the daughter of Melissa
Leo that'd be crazy yeah what do you see when
you look at me Denzel Washington I mean when I
come here you you you you take care me you
don't call ambulance you don't call police
why remember what I asked you you know what he
remembers the Titans yeah am I a good man or
bad man you asked me and you said you didn't
know only a good man would have said that or
the sociopath who refuses to acknowledge that
he's a bad guy you know he's our protagonist our
violent violent protag just saying there's
flaws in your argument there Enzo he's an
optimist Enzo Joker just thought he was ahead
of the curve but he knew he was a dog chasing
cars while not a religious fella I can appreciate
a movie where they don't shy away from it if it is
very much interwined and with the film and
the culture and it all makes I agree yeah
makes me think is he going to go to heaven or hell
after death equalizer 4 equalizer 4
Ever him and John Wick both fighting
underground oh man turning that beautiful
Town into hotels and casinos is I just love
just a silhouette of bad guys there yeah
the lighting's like we're silhouetted Pure
Evil hasn't been seen reading
one book this movie oh great
call there is some Western Samurai Vibes to it
stranger wandering in a town lone stranger Good
Samaritan a man
awful
damn how heroing it's like a
[Music] Inferno how awful this movie is doing
an excellent job at getting you invested in the
community yeah I really care about everyone even
them just saying like they're good people and now
we're like meeting the good people yeah normally
you rush past that [__] and and like you said
40 minutes of like gives him time to heal gives
time for us to like really love and hate these
guys he's got to take out two bosses which I like
he's got to take out the like debie boss and then
like ch's G to get himself in trouble I'm worried
about him his daughter why do you do that oh
uh Habit I'm neat and tell me who cooks for you
oh you will I would love to show you the real
food of alamonte would you come with me damn
son Hail Mary full of grace permanent Denzel
Riz cannot be stopped one condition you wear
your new hat it's the Hat it's the Hat it's
it's that hat man that's why they call him
Malcolm X he's got a whole row of them lining
up rebuild like your
back they see you as one of us now that's
amazing can't leave protect the people
found life now the stair seem uplifting but
will he die for his people I think he's about
to I'm still worried he is Jesus as where
this whole trilogy was going leading him
to sacrifice himself oh hey now turn and face
you straight on if you want to get a better
photograph turn it's not subtle that was a
terrible also real loud you volume on two
one who are you what were you doing on that
farm in sicy even better a farm that bundles
methamphetamine based narcotics told you on
the phone just a guy best passing I love he
just addresses at head on in every movie like I'm
this guy how did you know I was me you're reading
a tour guide for Rome were in alante and your
voice the way you pronounce your M it's a dry
sandpapery sound nice that's compliment you kill
him I look like a guy who kills people warming to
the possibility to [__] like like it or not
you're a person of interest I'm an interesting
person not even a little curious how I
found you took the same fairy Crossing
you noticed the security cameras on the
terminal building you rewind two weeks
saw the license plates for the VW damn
you'll uh do a deep search on the name
already in the works oh good good good
she raise your antenna I think it's I
think she's the daughter I think she's the
daughter when you said it you're like that's
perfect [__] you oh no cuz the
van a [__] Gio shouldn't be poking
your Italian nose in the places they
don't belong he's being a cop a good one not
in that town whoa great shot damn that so
cool oh no please tell me
it's just a taunting session
yeah oh that is really icky oh god oh my
god dude don't be
loud dude [Music]
[Applause]
dude a that's so sad we care about everyone now
like supporting characters the town in general
this is the first one in the trilogy that makes me
go what would I do in this position yeah they've
humanized him to such a level and even for this
geog guy you know I was like right there going
like man what would I do in this position it's
the camora the andang what you call mafia they
like cancer more cure he's the Cure he's going to
be the surgeon of the town I think he takes out
everybody except the big bad and the big bad and
them take each other out the way how John Q needed
a doctor he's going to be the doctor for this
city di to search go apparently you're a ghost
o not afraid of ghosts black shirt white wall
black shirt white jacket that Sicilian Farmers
Lorenzo vital ran a massive cyber Empire siphoning
money from offshore accounts government agencies
Pension funds so I'm off the hook for now I
got a idea cell we didn't know existed feel
like she's into him or something everyone is
she delivers her lines like Lil in the way she
blinks and everything be dealing with the locals
now they have their own agendas what they say is
not always what they mean aren't you you just
full of tips ah but you want to see that tip
you know what I mean why smuggle drugs into the
most secure port in the entire region I'll Circle
back to you with the answer when I'm done then
you can answer my question why me cuz you're the
daughter of the dead woman from the previous movie
you're cast very similarly I do believe that's
true restaurants sit down you know it's a
classic equalizer moment oh sit across from
him that's right you make IC cont that's
what I'm talking about go over there bring
your loud mouth over there yeah
you like being on another little
people's business trying very hard not to
be but you make it very challenging for me
everything in life is about timing now
unfortunately for you yours isn't very
good I'm starting to believe from the bottom
of my heart that this is where I'm supposed to
be that you and your friends do please do it
somewhere else you warning me
I'm preparing [Laughter] you
is that a TX
no oh yes let's go right there
that's the median nerve that I'm
compressing oh my God I love when they
educate scale from 1 to 10 that's a
two that's a three I go to four your [__] on
yourself you don't want that I
don't want that they don't want
that tell your comp that they can leave
beat oh my God he
is one little maneuver take the
gun out of your waist put it on
the table he had the opportunity
to shoot him and he still cannot
focus his brain's just Desiring he
could have easily shot got him right
there and the game is a foot yes and the
first action we've seen is a finger between
nerves little brother
syndrome all right take out these guys oh damn
oh God good stun Fork holy crap Wow real a real
person there that' be a dummy and it was such
good editing when they subbed it in woo well he's
taking out two of your guys wow that was intense
go for the Viking get the big one yes Viking with
wine yeah you got
this oh my God he's having
ooh ooh ooh oh look at the lighting
the lighting is so good oh [__]
that's damn there's call backs to the
first one in this one oh I have chills
that was amazing and the Halo oh the
Halo yeah he was waiting for that he
was cre he was G going down oh man yeah
there's a villain side here oh it's so
dark is anyone going to snitch on the what
went down at the restaurant M and he obviously
knows oh my God the F9 movie was happening Jason
Mamoa did this I'm Dante on Shante why sis why not
Ela Sardinia makes no sense Frank running drugs
through the most secure port in the region the
mainland faction took possession and Naples it's
easiest port to slip things through now I got to
say I I generally like Dakota Fanning but I'm I'm
not finding her very believable in this movie I
don't think she's a CIA agent and I do like her
I don't know what it is there's something about
her line deliveries that's it's interesting
because it doesn't quite play it's not reading
genuine to me I feel like she's acting and I think
since everyone else is so natural it's making it
stand out a bit yeah you can't Coast by and your
Man on Fire to Goodwill like to question these
men you son of a [__] so
that's your one you can't
interview now she knows where to start so what's
the deal I'm not here to negotiate I'm here to
give you an opportunity for what I need some
information and you're going to give it to
me well he just gave up the information she's very
intimidating Fanning but I feel like
I'd be terrified if I was part of this
family okay didn't look armed
but died like Elvis how' they know to shoot that
guy in the in the bathroom he was armed they but
how' they know there was a guy in bathroom was
AR they must have hurt I don't pooping sound of
pooping I'm pretty sure she's a
child someone's clearly telling her
things dude you're going to get yourself
killed yeah what is your what
is your dumb ass you're by
yourself there his finger oh his whole hand
all right so still attached I guess that was
extreme oh oh my God the ice bucket what kind of
knife is that that I don't know it's infomercial
and cut through pennies it was just like a
clean little sweep right there man worries
boat goes through Stak and hands like nothing
Chief barell is being attacked by who we don't
know but he has information regarding your
investigation this officer will escort you
to the hospital no excuse me probably
makes Chief Morell look non-corrupt he
definitely isn't Under Suspicion now it's
not terrorist it's theora careful let me
call you back in a minute do not start
your car we've learned oh if he hadn't
called Damn classic that explosion was crazy oh
oh my God this is a real horrifying aftermath I'm
used to starting car explosions but just moving
along but damn this is a this is real wow oh now
it's personal oh no this is a dangerous place for
her to be we're not looking for Terror it's theora
I would have trust a single person him those
doctors [Music] nobody all because he looked up a
[Music] van you mess with one
of us you mess with all of us
oh my God whoa is Denzel above them oh no my God
what land him a that dude's definitely def
in that ear now yeah I mean whatever ear is
left oh my God is Roberto coming out into
the open I killed your brother you're a
Long Way from Home American moer I'm where I'm
supposed to be here I am you do do I understand
weakness I understand pain I understand
death I understand suffering and because
of these people I'm starting to understand
peace you can't take that away from me woo
[__] you can take anything you want
take me here I am just don't do it here
this is the best place American so
these people can see and tell others
what they witness oh it's your choice it's
always my [Music] choice zero in what is
happen Eno
Enzo oh my God they're all recording oh yeah what
a beautiful moment but it won't last long cuz I'll
be back I'll be here I'll leave this place like a
war blew through it I'll be waiting for you hurry
up bad ass yeah oh he got the watch back he
got the watch back now it's real uh that's his
main accessory he went to them Shadows can't get
over it these guys are out of [Laughter] time oh
[Music] look oh yo he is cleaning house
[Music] oh my God I have become death oh
oh he just solved the just already took
care big bad's done oh oh never mind
like them we're just racist against
Italians yeah go teed Italians look
alike then dark [Laughter] lighting
die I like how not flashy this one is like
it's brutal and just G I like the oh god
oh wow the weight of sin just like cast
over this whole thing yeah movie is stayed
ominous whoa awesome
whoa brought the hanging
back you want some scared and suffering
before ouch ouch ouch ouch oh my God
it's home alone all over again ouch
oh I don't like it I don't like
it that's the problem the whole
rest of violence stepping on glass
I relate to I've lived through that
part man the camera work in this is really
great knowing where to place it and how to
handle reveals how this like and how it's
also mirroring the beginning of the film
you're going through the perspective of the
villain but now it's all forground violence
the beginning was background violence
cuz we've leveled up to like the tension
oh you are sick Robert yeah that guy's got
issues like yeah put a back together for a
[Music] reveal don't with me there you
go got what you asked for who are you
damn you have less than six minutes P the pills
backyard give him a chance to come kill him
one day when I is he a good guy or a bad guy
he's Dexter Morgan he's like stalking this Dy man
around his house I mean he deserves it but it's
horrifying oh my God is he going to put
him on the spikes he's going to be so
gross isn't he yeah how's he going
to what's the fat [Laughter] [Music]
wow does he March him into the center of the
square oh
damn the [__]
Godfather so tragic oh my God he's just like
watching him die this is crazy time he's like
guiding him to like wherever he wants him watching
him die [Music] slowly what ceremony is this so
beautiful sin the first Apple Robert's
also a thief did cleaned up the town bur
local he definitely wasted those
Peppers too is that your go bag
$366,500 wow so what's it for it's Greg
D's pension he's a brick layer his Union's
pension fund got hacked nine months ago okay
so you tracked down some guy's life savings to
a cyber ghost that no one has been able to find
for years it happens to be a drug smuggling Way
Station I didn't know that until I got in there
is this guy some friend of yours no gave him my
LIF once ah great what's this it's your pension
how did you was me why something like this for
a stranger I guess he is a good guy equalizes he
just does it yeah it's balances the scill someone
left this for you at the front desk got a meeting
with the director in 30 minutes he wants to meet
the person who broke up in the Italian situation
nicely done he was a good guy I was worried yeah
is that Mom look look at the just God damn it your
mother would be proud of you yeah I think I saw
a portrait look at your portrait black book oh
he's giv her all of [Music] his yes confirmed oh
so she's going to carry on the franchise she's
going to be The Equalizer now hope she learns
how to fight hope she learns how to murder hope
she learns how to do all the things cuz so far
she got a lot of help we won I this is our town
serial killer all right I'm moving to Italy been
a pleasure [Applause] America and [Applause] zo a
so in the beginning he saw death because he wanted
peace but now he's found peace so he doesn't need
to die and he's accepted that he's the Grim Reaper
himself I have become death destroyer of Italian
mafia for time oh man wow what a film man that
was great that was great wow W one of the best
shot action movies I've ever seen w wow wow wow
wow wow wow wow ladies and gentlemen if you're
listening to this on Apple Spotify rate it we have
just watched equalizer 3 literally moments ago
when we're going to talk about it with equalizing
efficiency still think they should have called the
three equalizer I feel like that title would have
helped serve the mood of this you know the box
office would have tripled had it thre equalized
absolutely what alrighty man Coy please please
um what did you think we'll do quick category
breakdowns denzo Washington's performance uh I
think that this is a contender for greatest sequel
uh and Trilogy in all of action largely because of
the weight that Denzel brings to everything like
this could been I don't think it would have gotten
a sequel much less a threequel if it hadn't been
for his gravitas his ability to make everything
feel so important the ability to have us judge him
but not in a judgmental way to assess him we were
always scrutinizing and feeling the weight of his
actions and the POV shots and the the Judgment
he was putting on himself but you always wanted
to see him as good and characters like Punisher
characters like you know Vigilantes to the scale
are always tricky because it's so easy to go like
oh violence is fine they don't make violence fine
at any point but it's his performance that allows
you to feel like yeah is it Justified and you
question yourself but if if the performance wasn't
a 10 then you wouldn't be able to yeah I thought
he was excellent I mean every single movie we've
gotten a different a different more intimate look
at him because the first one he he is more kept
that at a distance from us he's more mysterious
and he's just more like a badass act yeah he's
just doing awesome stuff yeah he's just a great
guy in that one and and you want him to become the
action hero and the second one does become more
reflective more intimate uh more introspective and
this one carries that on from looking at him in
in a way of of a like I think it's brilliant it's
not just a cool action movie Motif which I thought
that's maybe what they might have been doing and
then but you quickly pick up on that they're not
just doing this for cool int reintroduction into
equalizer 3 of starting it off with the villain's
perspective of him witnessing the vi like the it's
the villain being like this is a [__] yeah this
is violent situation we what is what is do this
who could do this what what is capable of doing
something this horrific and this brutal and by
himself MH and then to strip him down where he
is handicapped forcing him into a position to
slow down and take it all in and to reflect
like he's physically forced to reflect upon the
the situation and and then to have the religious
angles of course of the weight of sin C that is
you know um Weighing on him throughout this entire
experience and I I love it because it is very
philosophical it is very existential but a lot
of it is just performance and mood-based well it's
not exactly the like they don't go like too overt
about it other than like the visual references
yeah I think the ominous tone is is so many
different pieces it's the sound design it's the
the cinematography we talked about a ton because
it is stunning this might be the prettiest action
movie silhouette movie so shadowy and black and
white there's so much black and white like it's a
movie about good or bad black and white and they
frame it like that they're like what if this is
here and this is here and then the beginning being
violent in the background and then as we escalate
into accepting his violence the violence is in the
foreground and whether or not we we feel justified
in the violence that he has now chosen to take cuz
it's in front of us instead of behind us and I
thought that was a really interesting choice it
was it was really interesting because it's it's
this community that he's a part of that does need
him and they don't judge him like they accept him
pretty early on and they let him be a part they
just let him be part of it and he does this like
really violent acts but no one everyone's like but
he's helping us he's helping us and at the end of
the day we need him you know and you could still
see his hearts in the right place and I appreciate
for an act for a movie for a franchise that starts
off as just straight up like wikian it's such
it's such an action movie The First movie is such
an action movie and it this had the capacity to
potentially become pretentious you know o of like
I an art house action I get what you're trying to
do but come on like you know what if the allegory
for Jesus yeah it could have been easily but it
didn't ever go there and here they really stuck to
what they wanted to do of by the time they get to
the finale it it actually does not succumb to like
it's cool by appreciation and observation but it
does not ultim isn't cool like the death of that
guy is hard to watch they don't dissolve in into
just oh like well we were joking that it would do
which I really thought they were going to do I was
kind of afraid for a couple minutes I like you you
kind of get that cool catharsis moment when he
does kill crazy unhinged brother yeah yeah but
it's still unsettling and unnerving because he's
chewing it up he's enjoying it he's delighting in
the violence and that was so smart to have the two
bosses so you could get the action to satisfy that
but also be uncomfortable with that action and
then even more uncomfortable with the Slow Burn
walk death yeah it's like he does become death by
the end of this film uh he he is accepting of that
you know and that's his piece that is his piece
it's it is strange but for for a peculiar odd
character uh is something that is larger than
life uh I think it works for the world somehow
works like yeah I mean is it is it acceptable in
Real Life Society probably not but in a world like
this yeah [__] it I'll get on board for it why
not and I love that they leaned into the isolation
in the beginning and like him discovering and
slowing down because of his injuries so that
almost made me think like what if he had had to
slow down at any point in his life would he have
found peace sooner could he have and then there's
all the talk of like I'm right where I should be
there's all this talk of like this is the distance
between this and this this is the timing of this
and this and that's the the when he could have
slowed down so I love that they kind of wrap up
multiple subplots in one ending with this is where
he's meant to be this is the only time this could
have happened this is the only way this could
have happened and and it just beautifully tells
a mafia Story I mean it's called equalizer and
I've always thought that was such a funny title
for what it is for what it is yeah and and to me
he does in a lot of ways become The Equalizer by
the end of this film of yes he is the embodiment
of Darkness but he's doing it for good and they
don't shy away from him being the embodiment of
Darkness nor do they glorify it it was surprising
how they how they managed to like yeah we got to
frame it cool it's going to look cool but you're
not going to feel like it's cool you know when
you're watching it it's the anti-walmart movie
you like you know all those Walmart movies that
are like $5 bin like look at all this violence
blood and awesome this is like well that's cool
looking but why do I feel bad about it like it
doesn't feel like the glorification of action
movies it's it's almost a drama using action
to make it more dramatic like the action serves
the drama more than the drama serves the action
it is one of those things where I do feel like the
experience of performance and director really go
hand inand because they haven't shifted director
you know they start working together on training
day and they haven't shifted director since the
start of this franchise and you could feel the
evolution of them understanding that a lot of the
character of of Robert McCall is experienced more
tonal wise more more visual wise it's it's it's
all the unspoken stuff and while there some stuff
obviously spoken where they like they they mainly
speak the themes is what they speak you know but
the character growth and the trajectory a lot
like they're not saying a lot of things that were
saying but it's there it's very much it's very
much on screen and I I love that fuka I I feel
like his it's like The Equalizer ones are pretty
much near perfect first installment movie but as
these films have gotten heftier as these films
have gotten deeper uh I appreciate the maturity
of them and the will the boldness to go that way
because this to me is I could see it not being
audience satisfactory but I I haven't heard people
be disappointed with no I mean it's got like you
know four and a half stars or whatever and and the
IMDb is a little low it's like .1 which I don't
like but uh I love that it did well box office cuz
I'd love to see things like this get rewarded cuz
it didn't cost that much like you know this movie
is not that expensive compared to the Blockbusters
or even like you know High budget dramas out there
so to make more things like this where it's like
resonating with audiences enough to make a profit
trust the audience like this did but we didn't get
the there was some stuff I wish we got we didn't
get the cool I'm to just count my watch and we're
going to he didn't need it anymore we're going
to do some of those cool visuals need it anymore
any zip around evolved Sherlock holes now it's
slow Framing and now it's using foreground and
background now it's pacing I did like the POV of
like this it it's cool because the first movie
is you're observing and wondering questioning who
this person is and this movie takes so much to the
point of putting you into his that you actually go
into his own POV at one point and you're like oh
yeah observing him do cool violence is one thing
but when you're in it through his perspective it
is like this is a reflect experience you're
thinking like what would it be like to cause
this harm and like could I inflict this pain I
couldn't I think the movie in terms of some of
the the the weaker side which something that the
other ones kind of fall under the same camp is uh
kind I mean I love the sense of community that we
got here because that's where R mallic sells at
is getting involved with some kind of community
whether it be a warehouse of his co-workers or
a whole friendly Town Boston Boston or as a lift
driver or the city of Italy he's a man of the Town
yeah he's it I I love that Community Vibe I love
the whole sense there um because I really did care
about everyone and and like even like a character
like the geoc cop who I'm like I don't really know
this guy but man I really don't want him to die
yeah uh I really love that Enzo another one like
this is immediately captivated by this guy but the
the I did find some of the CIA investigating stuff
a tad boring there was about five minutes that I
was like was this filmed in a post screen it for
the fans they want to know where this plot Point
came from because a lot of it felt like re-shoot
or or additional photography like the entire
scene of like her interrogating that guy she's not
intimidating how did she get that out of him like
she literally said like I've got nothing for you
okay here it is yeah I mean a lot of the actual
CIA stuff that you would cut to I didn't find all
that interesting I thought it was just like plot
[__] like let's just get information out there
like we've been with him for too long in Rome
let's go over here yeah there was a lack of panach
the Italian mobster guys what I loved about them
was when they would um when you would get some of
their weird like uh idiosyncracies that not not
weird for them but that's part of the caption
that c like when they're just eating spaghetti and
talking about what they're going to do yeah and it
just feels so casual about it I like that again
though like I I do this this one is not really
affected by because it's so much about Robert
McCall's Journey that you're not it's so much
about witnessing like he is just he is becoming
fully accepting of of what he is MH uh because
because in the beginning he is like thinking of
just I might just off myself you know find peace
that way and instead he just finds a way to live
as death instead of giving into death it's I mean
we're all seeking peace so it's really interesting
that that's the answer for him and it made me go
like what would the answer for the average person
or maybe but the the there was something still
about the about checking in with the with the
villains that like yeah when they were doing
violent [__] I I was really compelled by it and
you do like hate them for it but plot wise they
weren't really the the first two had second this
that's secondary for me I feel like the CIA stuff
was really like a times very dull and then the
villain wise unless they were doing some actually
violent they weren't that interesting sure I think
the villains in the first two were definitely more
captivating but I kind of like that the villain in
this one was at times Denzel yes yeah so that that
made it you know what I mean like that balanced
that equalized the scales for for the villain
being a little weaker there was uh you know it
equalized my oh I could have used more of that
but I didn't want more of that because how much
I was with him I thought this was excellent man
I thought it was excellent overall and like these
other things were were so even compared to like
the runtime they they were featured in the film
very limited yeah I I do think um dakot of Fanning
was like properly cast in theory yeah because you
get an A Very incredible actress generally you get
someone that looks like Melissa Leo and you have
someone the right age it all works and then like
and you get the fan service of hey fire it didn't
work though it worked on paper and and I like her
normally I just didn't I I couldn't believe her
for someon I don't know if it's baby face I don't
know if it's line delivery I don't know if it's
the combination of everyone else being in like
really really grounded and she felt like she was
performing there was enough elements I was like I
yeah it it felt like I I felt all her choices sure
you know and and not in a not in a way that I felt
lived in that's fair everyone else felt very
lived in yeah even Roy yeah I could feel like
tired of being C I think you're trying to play
CIA vers but I don't believe you and that's hard
cuz that's such a tricky role to be like spouting
Exposition also this person over here this like
it's not an easy role but it's very predictable
TST yeah it took like five minutes to be like I
feel like to tell you what this person is right
it was a little too obvious and they were trying
to make it like a big thing and then they yeah
they didn't show the the frame until that you
would like even called how they're going to reveal
like no you're not yeah but man 90% of this movie
yeah most of it though great and in terms of like
focusing on dead I I I personally would still rank
two as my favorite I think uh one and two are tied
and this is a step down because one and two would
just be by my mood if I wanted to have a drama I'd
still watch two over this I wanted have an action
I'd still watch one over two but I think this is
still on par overall because I can't think of many
trilogies that are this good yeah no I mean I I
still think it it is like a necessary part of the
viewing experience and I I'm I I overall I love it
yeah overall I do I you know it's the problem when
you rank three and you put one as you put one
of them as three it sounds like you don't like
it no no I'm just I'm just acknowledging my mood
would determine what I watch but this would still
be the one I'd probably watch last doesn't make
this one lesser I agree it's just like those are
so incredible but as a Trilogy like I think this
is overall better than the John Wick 1 through
three uh cuz three dropped off for me a little bit
with John Wick and I think uh I don't even know
what else would be like this category certainly
not the Takens like this this is you know I mean
like Takens are just like violence is good no uh
I think this is one of the better action trilogies
they often compare Robert M like who win Robert
mccole or John wi I hear that conversation brought
up a lot but I'm like but in terms of a movie
they're so different they're so different they're
so like I think I think you can kind of see some
similarities between John Wick one and equalizer
one but as a franchise they're wildly different
is is John Wick is like a mythical fantasy world
yeah John Wick's like what's the coolest stunt we
could do this is like how violent can we make you
uncomfortably watch something and this one's like
let's just zero in our Robert McCall the more we
go you know yeah but I I do think as trilogies go
like this is up there for me this is I think it's
a solid ass Trilogy um yeah especially for an
action Trilogy it was hard to wait not see this
in theaters I'm so glad we did though like this
was one that I was like I kept seeing like I'd be
an AMC and be like ah like then this was so good
this is great this is great all right guys what
did you think about the equalizer 3 where would
you rank it um in terms of the which where you
would place it on the TR I don't know why I could
have just slowed down instead that you know what
I'm trying to say out of the three where would you
rank it uh leave a like on this video check us out
on patreon also where support the channel check
out one of our shirts I'm wearing one all the
time as should you and we will catch you all on
the flippity flip peace out reack [Music] Nation